how to use this microbiome project
template so that you can edit all of the
slides and kind of think about your
pitch and then how to actually put
everything together what each slide
should contain where do you find the
images things like that
so you were all given this template here
you want to State who you are give some
kind of a short and specific name to
your project don't turn it into a
research project this is a pitch so
you're trying to convince people that
this is a product a service some kind of
a dashboard maybe that you have created
and this is useful because it produces
value for the end user maybe it's a
business so let me kind of outline
what is the project summary in a few
kind of simple points and then you go
into what your analysis is and how that
turns into a specific solution so
instead of kind of talking about these
General slides let's take a look at an
example that we put together here with
psoriasis so so Malika shared with all
of you a list of projects that have
already been analyzed we have dashboards
we have the analysis results you can
kind of take that typically there's an
Associated publication that you can
start your literature review from so
let's take a look at how we took one of
those projects and kind of assembled the
different parts into this presentation
so what came out of this uh short
analysis we weren't really trying to
complete everything according to what
may be the amount of time that is needed
to actually fully complete this project
but just to give you an example we came
over this idea of probiotic bath
supplement for psoriasis treatment so
here you can put your logo your
University logo your team logo if you
have or maybe a company logo and you can
write out your names or your team name
something like that
here if you want to change the
background image if you're not clicked
on anything you can click on background
and you can actually choose an image
from your computer or even just search
on Google so the goal here is just to
help you kind of put something together
that is visually appealing and also
relevant to what your project is about
so after analyzing this data we started
talking about well what why exactly are
we talking about bath and and how does
the psoriasis skin condition
um you know what is that problem and
what exactly are we going to how exactly
are we going to address that problem
so this is just a summary kind of like
an abstract if you're writing a
publication
here we're talking about the problem
background so how many people how much
money is being spent on this problem
showing that this is a significant
problem that needs the solution that
we're going to present
this is the solution and the solution is
really to take something that is already
on the market bath salts and add a
probiotic supplement to it that
specifically focuses on patients with
psoriasis because they already use some
kind of water-based treatment a lot of
times and we identify this strain that
we thought was interesting because it
could be sourced fairly economically and
and we think could be effective in water
so the objective of these projects is to
use evidence from public domain data to
show that we can extract meaningful
insights and then potentially work on
those insights further so we took a bio
project after doing literature review We
identified a data set we studied it and
we identified a particular strain
confirmed that this is the strain also
that was mentioned in the relevant
publication but we also found some other
interesting
pathogenic bacteria that we could try
and think about so
then taking this Insight what we did is
we did additional literature review and
so here we show an abstract a particular
paper that talks about finding a
um a specific strain of a bacteria
called bacillus pumulus H2 that they use
they characterize the active substance
that has the potential to be used in
aquaculture for fish and so we think
that a similar approach could work for
skin again in water and that's why we
identified a producer of this particular
basilis pumulus this is what it looks
like and we think it's a feasible
proposal right so
our team uh here I just wanted to point
out if you want to replace these images
right it's kind of nice how they did it
in circles so what you can do is you can
select it and just click on replace
image and for example upload from
computer I'm just going to upload my
image my picture so here you can replace
your you know all of your team members
and try to put something relevant for
example you know data scientist with an
interest
in microbiome right that could be you
can also put your links to your profile
or something like that right here
Milestones so this is just a pitch this
pitch helps you put together the
evidence the idea kind of shape it form
it do some literature review what are
you going to do after that right so if
let's say this is a successful proposal
and the proposal you're interested
you're committed to it your team members
are as well maybe somebody tells you oh
this is an interesting research project
or maybe somebody thinks it's an
interesting company idea right you want
to take it further how long would it
take you to actually work on this
project and so here's some ideas about
thinking about that you can for example
start studying and complete literature
review there's a lot to know in this
area in this domain you want to make
sure that you're not just you know
taking the the first thing that pops out
of you you want to see what other people
have done in this space
you might want to reach out to potential
Partners you might want to think about
testing extensive testing on animal
models there's some animal models that
are designed for this kind of skin
conditions and then you know you might
want to think what what is the launch
date when are you going to be able to
launch something like that
after you have addressed all of these
points you now want to focus on
supplemental information information
that you can refer to as you're going
through your pitch if somebody asks you
a question and since not everyone is
going to come up with a question right
away you might even want to think of
some questions that you yourself are
asking and maybe you have already
addressed because you have asked those
questions as you worked on this project
so here you can list out some of those
questions and then provide some details
on how to how you
um kind of got to where you are
what types of considerations you might
have about maybe how to you know test
this how to test this on animal models
how to collect additional samples maybe
you would like to do that some
literature review for example there's a
lot of systematic literature reviews out
there just searching for systematic
literature reviews on psoriasis and skin
microbiome we identified some papers
that are summarized right here so this
might be an interesting kind of
additional piece of information you
might also want to think about how your
product is going to be used by your
target audience for example here we are
going to work with a bath Products
company and provide them our probiotic
supplement maybe specifically designed
and engineered for this problem and
that's how we're going to deliver it to
the consumer
and then another important question is
why now or why is this an important
problem to solve why is this relevant
you know today and so here we just have
an example the majority of the people
have mild psoriasis in only about two
percent of them use some kind of
specialized treatments and so the rest
are trying all kinds of you know
alternative approaches and so you can
see right here
where there is mild kind of pre-clinical
psoriasis is an opportunity to really
change the way that it develops into
much more severe conditions that are
very difficult to treat
it's important to refer to these
reference Publications so have a slide
or maybe have keep a document of all of
your references this will be important
to show that you know you've done
extensive research and also add here the
specifics so for example this is the
dashboard that we use so if somebody
wants to look at it they can see how to
find all of your data and finally
your conclusion slide so that on this
slide add your contact information maybe
add your link to your project that you
have submitted on omixlogic and of
course
the title and your team name
that's it